you've been asked i think on
reddit other big secrets that you know
that could land you and our country in
terrible trouble if you came out to the
public and you answered yes i wish i
could forget them so let me ask you just
about
secrecy in general
are these secrets or just other secrets
ones that the public will never know
or will it come out in 10 20 50 years i
guess the the deeper question is what is
the value of secrecy yeah transparency
the uh
the standard classification for all
human intelligence operations is is
something called 225x2 25x2 so 50 years
25 years times two years or times two
rounds
so
in essence anything that i've seen
has the first chance of becoming
public domain declassified after 50
years unless there's some congressional
requirement for it to be reviewed and
assessed earlier
so by then you know i'll be 80 something
years old or or potentially dead which
is either way
that's when it's it can come out
according to its typical classification
the
the value of secrets i
i have seen
is that secrets create
space
secrets give opportunity
for
security they give opportunity for
thinking they give space and space is an
incredibly advantageous thing to have if
you know something somebody else doesn't
know even if it's just 15 or 20 minutes
different you can direct you can change
the course of faith so i i find secrets
to be extremely valuable extremely
useful
even
at the place where secrets are being
kept from a large mass
part of what all americans need to
understand is that
one of the
one of the trade-offs to building
a
system of government that allows us to
be first world and wealthy and secure
and successful one of the trade-offs is
that we have given up a great deal of
personal freedom and one of the personal
freedoms that we give up is the freedom
of knowing
what we want to know
you get to know what the government
tells you you get to know what you need
to know or what you've learned yourself
but you don't get to know secrets
people who do get to know secrets know
them for a reason that's why it's called
a need to know
how difficult is it to maintain secrecy
it's surprisingly difficult as the best
technology changes uh it's also
surprisingly difficult as
uh as our culture becomes one where
people want notoriety people want to be
the person who breaks the secret
25 years ago 40 years ago that wasn't
the case there was a time in the united
states where if someone gave you a
secret
it was a point of personal honor not to
share the secret yes now we're in a
place where someone tells you a secret
like that could turn into a a twitter
post that gets you a bunch of thumbs up
and a bunch of likes or whatever else an
opportunity right so the value of
secrets has changed and now there's
almost a greater value on exposing
secrets than there is on keeping secrets
that's that makes it difficult to keep
secrets especially when technology is
going in the same direction yeah where
is the line
and by the way i'm one of those old
school people with the secrets i i think
it's a karma thing again back to the
trust
i think in the short term you can
benefit by sharing a secret
but in the long term if people know they
can trust you like the juicy is a secret
if it's a test of sorts
if if they know you can keep that secret
that means like you're somebody that
could be trusted and i believe that like
not just effectiveness in this life but
happiness in this life is is in forming
a circle of people you can trust right
we're taught that secrets and lies are
similar
in that they have a limited shelf life
if you treat them like food
secrets and lies have a very limited
shelf life
so if you cash in on them
while they're still fresh
you beat them before they spoil you get
to take the advantage take advantage of
it before they spoil however
trust
has no limit to its shelf life
so it's almost like you're trading a
short-term victory
and losing a long-term victory
it's always better to keep the secret
it's always better to let the lie live
because it will eventually come to light
from somebody else not from you because
it already has a limited shelf life but
what you win in exchange for not being
the one that cashed in on the secret is
immense trust
you